[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing some exciting news regarding
the upcoming third installment of
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore earlier today on the official
fantastic beasts twitter page actor jude
law who plays dumbledore spoke on camera
about the upcoming film revealing new
information the first proper trailer for
fantastic beasts came out this december
december 13th to be exact and since then
we're yet to see any new content
regarding the film
this is surprising particularly as the
release of the film is less than two
months away that feels amazing to say
particularly with all the setbacks that
the fantastic beasts franchise has gone
through so far
the film was originally scheduled for
november 2020 but was postponed due to
the need for a screenplay rewrite this
pushed the film back to november 2021
but then disaster struck in the form of
a pandemic and the film was postponed
again the new release date being july
2022 being pushed back even further with
all of that said however you might be
glad to hear that fantastic beast 3 is
now actually ahead of schedule and will
be released during easter of 2022 april
15th to be exact anyway i won't say
anymore for now let's let dumbledore
himself take over hello everyone
what a privilege it is
to play albus dumbledore
one of the world's most powerful
wizards a man
who's always one step ahead
a man who believes in the good
in people
and someone quick to offer wise if not
cryptic
words of advice
well this thursday february 24th a new
trailer
of fantastic beasts
the secrets of dumbledore will be
released
i'm thrilled to say that some of the
backstory
that helped
shape
the legendary wizard that we came to
love in harry potter will be revealed
in this film
mistakes are very high for him
and he needs
an unlikely team of heroes
to help him
face his greatest test yet
now
to gear up for the trailer we invite you
to join dumbledore's
first army
let us have
all your
favorite cosplay fan art
tattoos
and quotes anything dumbledore related
bask
in everything
albus stumbled or this wonderful
character that we've all
come to love
and there we have it on february 24th
fans can expect a new trailer for the
much anticipated film where even more
information can be expected to be
revealed about dumbledore's backstory
if you guys want coverage of these films
then this is the place so be sure to
subscribe to the channel and like the
video to help support future videos
that's it for today and remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
you